Charlie Hall won't make it that's why we
start at 10 am
and this afternoon we also had the
cancellation of Debbie marks so we start
at 3 P.M instead of 2 30.
and we have two free speakers today and
to follow the theme of yesterday we have
actually people from physics and
chemistry this today to really dovetail
what we talk about high level
philosophical angle of interoperability
I'd like to introduce our first speaker
Professor Mikhail
sorority from epfl he's a professor of
computational Science and modeling and
has been using machine learning to study
molecular Dynamics since digital
mechanics and materials
to make out the flower is yours thank
you very much for invitation it's pity
that I can't be there in person but
I'm here at least virtually so I'm gonna
Focus my talk on interpretability in
machine learning of matter
in the context of atomic scale modeling
so before I start I want to make sure
that I show you at least once the faces
of the people who did all of the work
that I'm gonna tell you about and then
before I start getting into examples of
how you can try to get the
interpretability in the use of machine
learning in this context
I wanted to give a little I also want to
give a little bit of context in terms of
uh what we are trying to achieve with
machine learning in this field so my uh
broadly speaking my field is quite
similar to that of of David limmer
um who will speak afterwards and the
broadly speaking my objective is to
achieve predictive modeling of the
behavior of matter starting from
um atomistic scale and from fundamental
equations of physics so essentially
if you want to study the behavior of
real this is to speak materials there
are two axes that you need to consider
in terms of the accuracy of your
simulation and one is the accuracy by
which you describe the electronic
structure of your system and all the
properties that you can compute by
solving the electronic structure problem
so most notably the interatomic energy
with number approximation can be
obtained by solving some approximations
of the electronic social problem the
more accurate the more expensive in
terms of computation now the other axis
involves a sampling
thermal fluctuations disorder quantum
mechanical fluctuations of the at of the
atoms themselves essentially of the
nuclear values of freedom and this is an
additional axis over which you can apply
different levels of actors you can go
from a static picture in which you
associate for instance a crystal with
the ideal perfect
structure to a high level of statistical
sampling accuracy which you could
incorporate on harmonic fluctuations
Quantum fluctuations disorder and
defects and so on and so forth so along
both of these axes a lot of progress has
been made over the past 20 years to
basically erode the
obstacles that limit you know getting to
the full-blown uh accurate treatment but
what is really still very very
complicated is being able to really
discover emergent physics let's say you
know phase Transitions and so on and so
forth without making any approximation
along the way
I think that you know at least the way I
use machine learning the main objective
is really to get around these enormous
computational bottleneck and basically a
sidestep the calculation of the
electronic structure and get the
forinters the interatomic potential uh
through a surrogate model so basically
you train the model on a certain number
of Great Clips configurations and then
be able to predict it over and over
again so that you can sample phase
Transitions and emergent phenomena
without having to worry about solving
over and over again in a direct
conversation problem something I will
not have much time to discuss but
something that we work a lot on
is the fact that you know one of the
advantages of solving electronic
structure problem is that you get a lot
out of a you know a self-consistent
solution and typically you can get all
sorts of other observables diaper
moments and more chemical shieldings
charge density hamiltonians you name it
so from the sort of a big picture point
of view uh which are what we're trying
to achieve is to get atomic structures
and feed them to different types of
machine learning
um
going basically from regression to do
inference which is basically what I was
talking about but also and I will show a
couple of examples to sort of interpret
the outcome of anatomistic simulation
that gives you an incredible level of
detail but it's you know sometimes it's
too much detail and in order to really
understand what's going on even from the
point of view of a physics-based
simulation you need to apply some kind
of automatic data reduction technique to
extract the Essential Elements out of a
simulation in which you have a hundred
thousand of atoms doing their thing so a
essential ingredient in all of these is
the representation that you use to
basically Mark the Cartesian coordinate
of the atoms into a form that is
mathematically more suitable to
uh perform all of the uh more or less
classic machine learning tasks that you
want to achieve and actually this would
be the first part of my presentation
today will be about this problem of
representation and how to sort of get
the structural representations that are
to an extent uh intuitively
understandable at least to a physicist
so one of the reasons to try and make a
representation
um
interpretable and physically inspired is
that in the process you can inject into
your model at the very origin a lot of
fundamental physical constraints for
instance one obvious constraint that is
very useful to embed into the
representation is to have basic uh
continuous symmetries built in so you
know the fact that the properties of a
molecule don't depend on the absolute
position in space that Scholars don't
depend on rotations and that also don't
depend on the order by which you label
the atoms all of these are fundamental
physical symmetries you are not really
building in some various system specific
inside it's very generic but very useful
because you basically simplify uh you
you basically avoid the seeing
structures that are distinct that are
the same structure as distinct
and at the same time and this is another
uh difficult issue is that you want to
achieve this immaterization without
losing the uh you know the objective of
having a complete description of a
structural response there are other
fundamental physical requirements such
as smoothness of the mapping that is
very useful to cooperate and something
which is extremely useful from a point
of view of uh chemistry and both the
level of deficiency of the model and its
interpretability
is to use representations that have an
additive structure
so an additive structure is something
which is really built into basic
thermodynamics you have an additive
property a extensive property in the
thermodynamic limit the property of a
macroscopic system can be broken down
into contributions from its parts and
many many traditional physical models
postulate that you can do this that you
can basically decompose something like
the energy of a crystal as a sum of
contributions associated with each of
its atoms
now this physical assumption has a
consequence from the point of view of
the mathematical form of the
representation that you use so for
instance if you use a feature vectors to
describe your structure if you want them
to reflect this additive decomposition
the vector that you associate with a
crystal should be written as a sum of
vectors that describe Atomic
environments and the same is true if you
use kernels and in many ways the same is
true also if you use a non-linear models
so
essentially this locality from a
fundamental point of view incorporates a
notion of nearsightedness something
which is built very deeply into the uh
into you know the ethos almost of
chemistry and condensate matter of
physics but also from a practical point
of view it's very useful because it
makes your models transferable you know
that you learn the behavior of the
pieces of your
materials and then you can use training
on relatively simple systems to make
predictions into larger and more
complicated structures into which some
unexpected emerging physical phenomena
may arise
and I should also say that
um the centrality of representations
into this exercise of doing machine
learning for chemistry and physics is I
mean it's perhaps a little bit of a
circular argument but it's perhaps also
um made apparent by the number of
different families of representations
that have been proposed over the past 10
or 15 years and actually one of the
things that we have been working on over
the past three or four years is
essentially trying to put some order
into this jungle and this zoo of
alternative Frameworks and what we have
realized is that actually the vast
majority of these descriptors can be
expressed as a projection on a suitable
basis of relatively abstract objects it
can be understood as symmetrized
correlations of the neighbor density so
you know for all of you with our
background in statistical physics
basically we describe individual
structures in terms of the pair
correlation function the three body
correction function and so on and so
forth and this hierarchy allows you to
achieve a complete description of a
structure
while incorporating all of the basic
symmetries so we have been really
working a lot on this and we have been
you know showing how not only you can
build a fully symmetric uh descriptors
that are suitable to treat scalar
properties but you can also build
equivalent descriptors that you can use
to learn tensors you can actually
generalize this framework to also you
know the the main limitation to the
nearsightedness principle is basically a
non-screened electrostatic interactions
and we have also found a way to
incorporate this kind of long-range
physical correlations into a
semi-local descriptor that is very
efficient if you want to learn about
long-range the localized physics and
those of you who are perhaps a little
bit more familiar with the modern
developments in machine learning for
chemistry might have heard a lot of
about
equivalent machine learning Frameworks
and actually you can show that even
these equivalent Frameworks that on this
surface are usually discussed in the
language of neural networks can actually
be in mapped almost one to one with the
generalization of these correlations in
which basically you put you you look at
correlations between densities centered
on different atoms and by doing this
that's how you populate a element of you
know message passing
structure into the descriptors now again
this is mostly for those of you who have
a little bit of familiarity with the
prevariant machine learning Frameworks
the way you implement these things in
practice and the way you can show the
link with the
um equivalent machine learning for
chemistry is basically by picking a
smart basis to expand your neighbor
density and a smart basis since we want
to enforce symmetries is a basis that is
adapted to the O3 group basically a
basis of radial functions and spherical
harmonics and if you do that basically
you can show that the coefficients of
the density act themselves as equivalent
descriptors and you can then and this is
something again that will make the
physicists in the audience very happy
you can basically build higher order
correlations of the atom density by
applying an angular momentum some rule
to lower body or their representations
okay so basically this gives you a
hierarchy of equivalence descriptors
that transform like angular momenta and
you can use it to expand any tensorial
property
so here basically the level of
interpretation was at the level of
incorporating physical principles into
the model but now I also want to discuss
a little bit how you can interpret the
functioning of a model and one way of
interpreting the functioning of a model
is basically to start by recognizing
that we're using as features this for
instance you know one of the entries in
this uh higher he is a new equal to
correlation basically a true neighbor
what you would call a free body
correlation of the atom density this is
equivalent to evaluating the density at
two points and then averaging over
rotations so that you obtain an object
that describes three body correlations a
disinvariant to the absolute orientation
medium molecules so if you do that what
you obtain is basically something which
is equivalent to evaluating a single
density in shoe points
and so you see that the these kind of
form is very redundant and actually
these descriptors only depend on two
distances in one angle
and actually if you take the sharp
density limit of this descriptor which
you can recognize that actually these
descriptors correspond to a sum over two
Neighbors
of Delta functions that can that
basically track the distance and the
angle between Pairs of Neighbors
and then what you can recognize is that
you build the linear regression model
using on the using these descriptors a
linear regression model is basically you
know this is a little bit of a more
General formulation but basically this
is a combination a linear combination of
Weights that describe a potential for
instance with this scripture that
describes the structure and since we are
basically describing the structure with
the sum of Deltas this is basically a
disc a potential depends on shoe
distance is in one angle so again these
are very familiar uh form for expanding
a potential and
uh arises naturally from the use of
these representation so in a certain
sense physics-based models are really
very closely related to the models that
we build on these type of descriptors
now another aspect in which you can
introspect your model to try and extract
some
interpretation and some understanding
about the underlying physics is trying
to characterize a little bit better the
locality of your model so all of these
descriptors are based on these
atom-centered correlations and usually
to compute them in practice so you
decide a cut off up to which you perform
your expansion and then you can vary the
cutoff and check how accurate your model
is
so here you can see learning curve so
here I'm trying to learn the atomization
energy of some small organic molecules
and I'm trying to do this learning
exercise and building learning curves as
a function of the cutoff radius that I'm
using and what you can see here is that
actually if you have a small amount of
training data a very short range cut off
of just two long term actually gives the
best performing model and the reason is
that essentially the covalent bond is
short ranged and so it's pointless to if
you have a small amount of data it's
pointless to distract your model to
learn long range correlations is better
to get it focused on these short range
information that contains a lot of the
information on the stability of a
molecule and then if you have more data
you can basically increase the cutoff
distance and then you avoid the
saturation of the model and I mean this
is a horribly hand wavy procedure but I
think that you can read into the
envelope of these learning curves an
indication of the amount of energy
information that is available within a
certain cutoff from a central atom
and actually I mean this is perhaps you
know how this interpretability helps you
also build better models uh at this
point you can also recognize that
interactions between atoms and molecules
are multi-scale in nature and then you
can build the model that is multi-scale
in nature waiting uh descriptors built
along different length scales and
achieving a model that is more accurate
for each size of the uh data set because
it basically reflects the natural length
scales of the different interactions
another example of how you can recover
some traditional physical insights or
here probably more publicly chemical
insights is but basically by looking at
how you can learn the behavior of
different atoms so something I didn't
tell you is that these atom density
descriptors are basically stratified
depending on the nature of the different
atoms very much like you would Define a
partial correlation functions in a
scattering experiment
similarly here we compute a separate
channel for the density of oxygen carbon
and hydrogen
and then you can ask yourself okay but
you know what if I have 50 elements then
I need to learn the behavior of 50
independent channels this is a nightmare
from the point of view of that
efficiency and also from the point of
view of memory requirements
so actually what you can do very very
unwillingly is to use a classical
elements picture in which you say well
actually there are only there is only a
small number of elements that matter and
they can describe all of the actual
chemical elements as a combination of
this small number of let's call them a
chemical archetypes okay and then you
can build a model in which you learn
simultaneously the a composition of the
actual chemical elements in terms of
this abstract elements and the target
property in this case the cohesive
energy of some crystals and then what is
very nice is that if you now now if you
take you know just two elements
basically each actual chemical element
is a vector in two dimensions and you
can plot these vectors into dimensions
and what I find very reassuring is that
the best alchemical composition is one
that clusters together elements that
belong to the same
column in the periodic table so in a
certain sense we ReDiscover the periodic
table by a data treatment procedure
so the last bit that I wanted to discuss
say something a little bit different
and has more to do with unsupervised
learning so as I mentioned you run large
complicated simulations for example you
can emulate all the conformers of some
uh small molecules and then in this
paper uh Mariana Rossi uh the UPI was
trying to understand how absorption of
this molecule on a Surface would modify
the conformation landscape and so here
each point each of the gray points
correspond to a conformer in the gas
phase and you can see that basically
interaction with surfaces with very
little changes between the different
Noble Metals
um
of course basically restricts the number
of available conformers and modulates
their stability and if you use a
protonated so basically a Charged
molecule the landscape change a little
bit more
so you can use this also for instance to
classify different uh
types of polymorphs of a molecular
crystal is a big problem for the
pharmaceutical Industries and this is
here you can get some understanding of
what is the relationship between parking
and stability and actually we have been
trying to make so usually we used to do
these things by doing something like a
principal component analysis or a kernel
PCA or a note encoder so basically just
trying to look to recurring patterns in
the structure of the materials but
lately we have started also uh
incorporating information on the target
so basically trying to build the maps
that simultaneously differentiate
between structures that are
configurationally diverse and also can
give a good linear prediction of an
interesting property and by doing this
you actually get much better and much
more insightful classification for
instance of the different Polymers of
carbon so this is a data set constructed
with a random search as we also get
pretty absurd the simple cubic carbon
and you see how it's separated out much
much more nicely we are also using a
gain for monogram crystals to try and
understand what makes a molecular
Crystal stable and here we are really
basically combining many different types
of machine learning techniques to try
and provide tools to interpret large
data sets recognizing more efficiently
the kind of design principles that
people have been fishing for by manually
inspecting a large databases
uh something very quickly I wanted to
discuss is something that we call
knockout machine learning models so I
think that in the computer science
Community these are called ablation
studies and here basically the idea is
that if you have a descriptor that is uh
interpretable you can actually use uh
you can manipulate this script or to
understand something about the physics
of your system so for instance you can
switch you know you can again change the
cutoff distance
remove angular information and use only
pair correlations and you can see how
these experiments change the ultimate
accuracy of your model and by doing this
you can understand which structural
features are key to determine the
properties of your material or your
molecules and you know you're using
these also for instance to characterize
the synthesizability of different
materials
um now basically since we have uh less
than five minutes left I would quickly
wrap up so that we have perhaps time for
one or two questions and basically I
would say that from my perspective in
terms of the application of machine
learning through automistic modeling
there is a very clear
um and widely recognized into the
community appreciation of the fact that
the Divide between data-driven and
physics-based approaches is not so sharp
and is not so impermeable so there is a
lot of mixtures a lot of
cross-contamination which is being a
very very effective in advancing the
field both from the point of view of the
accuracy of the models and also from the
point of view of how much we understand
um about the fees not only about the
model but about the physics that we are
trying to describe and something which I
think is an interesting question
particularly you know interacting with
the scientists from other disciplines is
up to which point physics-based players
are useful what makes them very useful
in my field is the fact that usually you
don't have unlimited amounts of data and
so basically being that efficient is
quite a significant added value
and I think that actually the concept of
interpretability I have a little bit of
mixed feelings about it because contrary
to the idea of using physics-based
priors what interpretability means
depends a lot on kind of a subjective
viewpoint on what is interoperable by
the human mind and so I think it's very
interesting to see what we gain by
trying to enforce interpretability and
what we lose
so this is my last slide so thank you
for your attention and if we have one
question I would be happy to answer
thank you
you have one quick question
do we have one quick question
yes check
you can ask it if you can't hear me it's
okay you can just repeat it then you
just repeat it okay he it seemed like
most of the that was great talk but it
seems thank you the approach was very
heavily focused on kind of classical
regression kind of started up and
modernized and the unsupervised learning
deep Network approach was not so long
repeat long press repeat that was a
great talk it seemed like a lot of the
methods that you're using are modern
updates of classical
regression-based approaches which I
think is great and it seemed like the
unsupervised learning deep Network stuff
that you know any student under the age
of 25 is very excited about was less
less focused how do you think those two
things go together
so there is there are two aspects so one
is the fact that
if you want to incorporate symmetries uh
and we we have a actually we have a
recent paper about these uh so if you
want to incorporate symmetries into your
models these really you know
symmetricize your hands so the only way
you can build a non-linear combinations
of irreducible representations of SO3 so
that they are still irreducible
representations of SO3 is basically by
doing a clutch Corbin product
so if you actually look at the
equivalent machine learning models that
are currently you know what the cool
kids under 25 are excited about
they are basically doing these so you
are just stacking several of this CG uh
products and so there isn't really much
fundamental difference between uh you
know building these features and then
using them in a linear regression
framework and using something like
tensor field networks they are doing
pretty much the same thing so there is
this aspect and then the other aspect
that I mentioned is the fact that
usually deep models are varied at 100
and if you need to learn energies that
are computed you know with Quantum Monte
Carlo or with couple clusters you know
you can afford a few thousand structures
you can throw a lot of CPU time and get
a few hundred thousands but you can't
get 10 billion so that is another aspect
which I think gives at least for the
moment a Competitive Edge to relatively
simple models
but things will probably change even
just sociologically you know
thank you
thank you so we have a whole hour but
right now I have another break I think
one first break at 10 30. and I will
come back at 11 I have a hopeful hour to
continue this discussion so see you guys
in half an hour
and come back in half an hour thank you
very much
[Applause]